hello welcome to this video playing ESO
call and this is one of those people we
have a terrible score so I think mostly
due to time and time nonsense so let's
play quick I remember that I had this
against him yeah that a 5 a-5 a 5-4
looks absolutely silly but it is not bad
absolutely not bad I can play like that
just want to control before here yeah
that that mo of him playing some random
not very good moves quickly as kind of
shaping up already yeah blacks position
looks pretty awful and with this green
moving around and stuff but probably
blundering something and losing and so
okay night coming to f4 which in itself
is no problem can also take b7 them and
my chick made it okay I'll just take it
so might you have form that is not
threatening anything at all I think
check
so I'm not download down the clock
that's good I'm two pawns up but he's
got some kind of hmm wake I taking ideas
tweenage three takes check back neither
form something something weird like that
could work Queen 83 cheeks check yes
really kicks a check on g4 and king of
one knows playing look to d8 talk about
a move that I had not looked at in the
slightest I mean not not even remotely
consider that move ok but he looked at
default that certainly makes some sense
I wonder if night f oneness my it's got
f5 as well
I can pratik then
night everyone what does he doing then
some caption tea for my idea is 93
coordinating now it's going night h3 and
blundering the Queen oh my god yeah this
is the kind of kind of stuff that I love
to overlook yeah position is kind of
shaky it really is love a good defensive
move here on what better counter taking
move d 5 would be good if I could pull
that off but it doesn't seem to work
don't really see something great here to
be honest I simply hate to defend stuff
like that even though it might be
completely winning simply hate to play
against those kind of those kind of
attacks d5 the ship's III takes on e6
can I do that after cannot wait any
longer oh come on that is good it's
working for black yeah really so I dig
f7 there Kimmy 8 Bishop takes you five
wins check other stuff also wins come on
let's reading right don't don't give me
that King g7 f8 queen is winning chat
Queen for Queenie seven and then that
resides so I got one in yeah I had many
games like that against him way just Yap
let some random moves got into a lost
position and then some more swindled out
of that I really am NOT great at those
kind of situations okay here rook takes
f7 to typical mercilessness of the
engine to forget seven white wins oh my
I mean because of 95 but it's just super
cold blooded move will be seven Enders
like why doing something
okay okay i took that my could've played
night f0 here yeah can the engine is
just always 1.5 1.6 sentient basically
says I'm winning and check but it's
still not fun to play engine gives be
for preventing c5 makes lots of sense
it's that bad all rights it's worse than
before but I'm Casey 5d five and yeah
this losers so got that one right at
least but this is a playable move funny
enough i am not getting it and this just
this and now okay Gary and this I have
to go
the engine thinks this is equal funny
enough wow what a position I mean the
likelihood of some kind of Perpetual is
high but also the likelihood of someone
blundering okay and this is winning now
and check yeah it's a force made here
this is also or Queenie seven I just saw
this one which is checkmate also pretty
good yeah let to get one in against one
of the guys I am scoring very very badly
even though it shouldn't be I mean terms
of rating sometimes you have those
people wear which similar or even worse
ratings which is simply cannot deal deal
with well okay well thanks for watching